until Zionism came about Jews flourished
as as distinctly religious Jewish
communities and they weren't massacred
on the contrary they went to these Arab
and Muslim lands to escape persecution
uh from the Crusades from the
Inquisition and from many other trials
and tribulations and the um and even
World War II uh the Arab and Muslim
lands opened their hearts opened their
lands and uh provided a safe haven and a
gracious Hospitality for the Jewish
people clearly they we we have different
religion and yet uh we were we were
accepted in these Muslim and Arab we
believe in one God and we were accepted
we have different ways of serving God
but yet as I we were respected and even
the Muslim religion requires of that of
of the uh the Muslim people to to
provide protection and hospitality and
they did uh carry that out that's clear
nobody could refute this fact